the jurgen experience
yeah but i think that there's just very
little that people really
you know the level of understanding that
people have like imagine the fact that
we were [ __ ] around like nuclear
bombs like 70 years ago like no one even
really knew what was
happening it's just like accidental like
just dropping them all the time in the
ocean oh yeah it's like [ __ ] videos
are insane dude nuts i showed them to a
friend of mine the other night at dinner
like this is what it looked like and you
see the look on his face when the the
[ __ ] mile high wall of water comes
out of the ocean
it's so big it doesn't even make sense
to the best holy [ __ ] right now when
everyone's talking about this russian
hypersonic
missile like can you believe this weapon
that like russia has like i was like
wait a second the u.s spends like 10 to
20 times the amount of money on weapons
than russia that we have all that [ __ ] i
mean but the hypersonic missile i mean
that's i you know that's probably what
those ufos quote ufos from the
um the videos that were circulating a
couple year are just like you know
because those things are [ __ ] crazy
man the ramjet [ __ ] like that but it's
crazy it's like art bell
when we used to drive on tour back in
the day like it'd be like you'd listen
to coast to coast at night there's
nothing else but you could find that
scary ass [ __ ] and you'd be looking over
like that
you know
arizona skyline like looking for [ __ ]
driving in the middle of the night
hearing this art belt that's the best
and like around the time we were doing
that like that's when art bell's like
family got kidnapped you're like what
the [ __ ] is going on and george nori
would come on and then they were talking
about ram jets and all kinds of [ __ ]
like i mean that [ __ ] it's actually i
think the ram jets what the power's the
sr-71 like essentially like it takes a
whole tank of fuel to get that thing
just up and going like mock one or two
whatever and then they have to refuel it
to get it like ramming whatever
but like those so they refill them in
the sky yeah it takes a whole
tank to get them where they that's the
wildest [ __ ] ever pumping gas in the sky
dude if you see like dude
the potential of these hypersonic
missiles have you yeah
dude they like without even a warhead
they can they have like a megaton
explosion just from the velocity of
the speed they can get like mach 15 or
something and they can change course
yeah they can't just
predict oh this one's going to go to
seattle no it can turn left you can you
can go south you know that scene and
like it's like superman too where they
have the icbm like he's like riding it
like yeah dude
i think you're right i think that's
probably a lot of what those ufo
sightings were i think a lot of the
other ones are drones like the ones like
this the the famous one is that tic tac
one that they found off the coast of san
diego i think in 2004 a commander david
fravor saw this object that they had
tracked they even recalibrated their
device apparently to make sure that it
was accurate but they they've
read this thing at more than 50 000 feet
above sea level it got down to 50 feet
in less than a second yeah and they
don't know what it is and they followed
it around with their jets and then the
people on the nimitz said yeah we've
been seeing these for a couple weeks
these like super credible naval pilots
pilots guys who really understand like
what's possible and not possible and
they watch these things dart off and
just vanish with the kind of speed that
like is just impossible no propulsion uh
signature it doesn't like show that like
anything's coming out the back like a
normal jet it just looks like a tic tac
and it goes at an impossible speed like
what the [ __ ] is that
that might be a drone it might be some
crazy [ __ ] drone that they've been
working on for decades just not telling
us about it oh for sure when i saw the
pentagon was talking about ufos and they
were talking about things or from alien
worlds i'm like yeah really or maybe you
guys have been making some cool [ __ ]
[ __ ] and you don't want everybody to
know yeah
and you're like oh yeah it's not us we
don't have any hypersonic [ __ ] ufo
looking tic tacs it's like back to phil
hartman right when he does the unfrozen
caveman lawyer he's like i'm not
familiar with your modern ways
this legal system but i do know my
clients entitled to 3.5 million in
punitive damages
it's alien technology
why would the pentagon ever tell us
because i always wondered like because
tom delong he actually worked with the
government like they brought him in to
talk about aliens because he's that much
of an alien freak and i think they
thought that would like help you know
dude he told me he he was like they're
they're cloaked they're all above us
they're cloaked and well they're
scanning and honestly what he was
describing was like
satellites tapping into all of our
phones and listening to everything we do
which is i think actually happening yeah
but they don't even need satellites to
do that no they get right into the
system they can listen to everything you
say
that's uh gavin becker who's the
security expert on my podcast was
explaining they used to have to you used
to have a clickable link it used to be a
thing you had to click and then you
would accidentally without your
knowledge rather download some sort of a
software that would take over your phone
now they don't need that so now they
just need your phone number they need
your they get your phone number they're
just listening to you they're doing
they're watching everything you do they
can do whatever they want now imagine
the stupid conversations that these
people have to listen to
yeah well it makes people more aware of
how [ __ ] stupid your conversations
are if you think they can come up in a
trial with johnny depp and amber heard
oh my god that kind of [ __ ] when you
realize like oh my god like everything
you've ever said and he's now reading
like
text messages and [ __ ] the vessel i've
donated my jizz to